bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans sa vous regarde ce soir
l'architecte du rejet de la loi
immigration bonsoir Olivier Marlec
bonsoir merci d'être notre grand témoin
ce soir patron des républicains à
l'Assemblée ellisabeth borne vous a reçu
ce matin à Matignon on va bien sûr en
parler négociation de la dernière chance
jusqu'où la droite est prête à faire des
compromis vous nous le direz tout à
l'heure dans la deuxème partie notre
grand débat ce soir vers la fin des
énergies fossiles les pays du monde
entier ont approuvé à la COP 28 de Dubaï
un accord qualifié d'historique pétrole
gaz et charbon pour la première fois
dans l'histoire des conférences sur le
climat l'idée qu'il faille transitionner
hors des combustibles fossiles est
écrite noir sur blanc et chaque mot est
pesé alors qu'est-ce que ça va changer
concrètement grand débat dans un instant
sur ce plateau avec mes invités enfin
nosa franchi ce soir le parti prix de
yel Goz le billet Europe de Richard
verli et puis Bourbon Express l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée à la fin de cette
émission avec Stéphanie des pierres
voilà pour le programme vous me suivez
Olivier maranex et bien ça vous regarde
c'est
[Musique]
parti il avait le sourire sultan aljaber
le président la COP 28 pase fier d'avoir
arraché un accord sur la sortie
progressive des fossiles à Dubaï tôt ce
matin après trois décennies de
tergiversation autour de la cause
principale du réchauffement climatique
est-ce que ce compromis est le plus
important depuis l'accord de Paris vous
allez nous le dire Marjoline mier milfer
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes député renaissance de
l'zer vice-présidente de la Commission
du développement durable à l'Assemblée
et vous étiez à Dubaï à cette COP 28
bonsoir Julien Bayou bonsoir merci être
là député écologiste de Paris bonsoir
jean-jousel bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
climatologue ancien président du GC
enfin bonsoir Sarah Roussel bienvenue
vous êtes porte-parole de Greenpeace
Olivier marlex bien sûr vous intervenez
quand vous le souhaitez le grand
défenseur du nucléaire que vous êtes
j'en suis sûr a plein de choses à dire
on va commencer par planter le décor cet
accord que contient-il et quelles sont
les principales réactions soyons clairs
c'est avec St c'est avec Valérie
Brochard bien sûr
bonsoir Valérie bonsoir bonsoir à tous
Alors Valérie un accord on le craignait
on craignait que il n'y a rien mais oui
un accord a bien été trouvé ce matin et
oui vous avez raison meri ça partait
pourtant ça partait pourtant très très
mal organiser une convention
internationale sur le climat au royaume
des hydrocarbures fallait oser fallait
oser une COP à Dubaï donc aux Émirats
arabe uni présidé par sultane Ahmed
aljberber par ailleurs patron d'une
société pétrolière un président de de de
Cop qui accueilli à bras ouvert plus de
2500 lobéistes des énergies faossil
écoutez on aurait voulu se moquer de la
lutte contre le changement climatique on
ne s'y serait pas pris autrement et
pourtant et pourtant Myriam voici ce qui
a été conclu cette
nuit nous devons être
fier de notre réussite historique vous
avez entendu historique c'est historique
des applaudissement standing ovation
pour cet accord alors quoi alors quoi
fermeture des usines à charbon on
rebouche les puits de pétrole qu'est-ce
qu'il contient exactement cet accord on
va on va regarder d'un peu d'un peu plus
près le texte appelle à transitionné
hors des énergies fossiles dans les
systèmes énergétiques d'une manière
juste ordonnée et équitable à ah oui
d'accord ah d'accord on transensitionne
he bon c'est c'est pas c'est pas foufou
he mais Celan tienne écoutez les pays
arabes la Chine s'extasie toute la
communauté internationale a signé cet
accord mais certains pays évidemment
auraient préféré aller beaucoup plus
loin
cela pourrait ne pas être suffisant
c'est pourquoi ce texte n'est pour nous
en tant qu'Union européenne en tant
qu'Allemagne qu'un point de
départ c'est un compromis raisonnable il
est évident que j'aurais souhaité une
formulation encore plus forte et sans
parler sans parler du tweet d'Emmanuel
Macron du président de de la République
qui salue une étape importante bon on
l'a connu plus plus en jouer non
Emmanuel Macron profite surtout dans son
tweet de souligner que la France et une
vingtaine d'autres pays ont fait le pari
du nucléaire un Paris mentionné appuyé
dans l'accord de la COP 28 et là et là
je peux vous dire Merriam que pour la
ministre de la transition énergétique là
là c'est historique pour agès agès
panierunach applaudi dès demain je la
cite le texte mentionne à plusieurs
reprises la contribution de l'énergie
nucléaire à la lutte contre le
changement climatique donc si je résume
dans cet accord on trouve du nucléaire
une formule plus que timoré sur les
énergies fossiles autant vous dire que
le groupe écologiste cet après-midi dans
l'émicycle à l'Assemblée tu es très en
colère on les regarde 2023 est l'année
la plus chaude jamais enregistrée le
taux de CO2 dans l'atmosphère est le
plus élevé depuis 14 millions d'années
sécheresse incendie inondation la COP 28
n'aura pas réglé le problème l'accord
mentionne certes les énergies fossiles
mais pour lui accoller une terminologie
floue transitioning away pas d'objectif
précis et daté rien de contraignant ni
sur l'arrêt de la consommation ni sur
l'arrêt de la production alors
historique pour les uns flou pour les
autres mais après tout puisquon arrive à
des avancées même minimes au pays de de
l'or noir qui sait on arrivera peut-être
à la fin la fin totale de des énergies
fausile pour la prochaine COP la
prochaine COP qui aura lieu en
Azerbaïdjan pays producteur de de
pétrole et et de gaz je vous laisse
méditer là-dessus avec eux merci
beaucoup merci Valérie Marjoline mier
milfer vous parlez d'un corps historique
vous bah oui moi je le pense parce que
vous avez introduit quand même en disant
que ça fait 30 ans qu'on tergiversait
sur les énergies fossiles et que là pour
la première fois on inscrit inscrit les
énergies fossiles dans un texte qui est
signé par près de 200 pays dans le monde
et vous l'avez dit alors avec un peu
d'ironie moi je rejoints pas ce cette
vision ironique là mais dans un pays qui
justement a fait sa sa richesse sur le
pétrole donc c'est un aller au cur d'un
pays comme ça qui effectivement s'engage
pour dire ok on accepte qu'on va faire
une transition et sortir des énergies
fossiles c'est quand même historique
c'est alors c'est sûr que c'est pas la
fin du match mais c'est quand même un un
moment qu'il faut applaudir moi je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut qu'on
ait en en règle commune avec les enjeux
climatiques c'est qu'il faut qu'on fête
nos victoire et que le lendemain on
reprenne le boulot et là aujourd'hui
c'est le jour d'une F Jean jousel c'est
vrai que le terme utilisé donc il n a
pas la sortie le fameux Faing out qui
était un peu tabou notamment pour les
pays pétroliers donc la transitioning
away c'est c'est on transitionne hors de
on s'éloigne bref c'est une trajectoire
qui est montrée ça ressem sememble quand
même à une sortie progressive qui est
actée ça c'est pas rien non oui tout le
problème avec tous les toutes les
fossiles ensemble oui bonsoir tout le
problème c'est le le problème de la
sortie progressive c'est-à-dire qu'on va
délibérément vers les 3 degrés bien sûr
ce qui est affiché dans le dans le texte
reconnaît
l'urgence pique des émissions en 2025
nécessité de diminution de 43 % en 2030
60 % 2035 tout ça c'est très bien la
réalité c'est quoi c'est que les
producteurs de fossiles nous disent que
les émissions vont augmenter d'ici 2030
qu'onatteindra pas le pic avant 2030
donc et c'est bien cela le problème la
transition n'y a aucun objectif aucune
ambition dans cette transition et bien
sûr dire qu'on va sortir en en 2050 bon
ça va être difficile donc la neutralité
carbone en 2050 vous n croyez pas
comment on y arrivera pas pour vous là
actuellement on est disons il faut bien
comprendre que que c'est aujourd'hui
entre aujourd'hui et 2030 qu'on décide
du climat de l'après 2050 globalement
les 10 prochaines années alors l'Europe
a introduit cette notion de de des 10
années importantes mais voilà oui mais
la réalité c'est que les pays
producteurs enfin les pays disons du
secteur fossile ne l'entendent pas cette
oreille il nous annonce très clairement
que la la production va continuer à
augmenter et c'est quand même bien cela
qu'il va y avoir de nouveaux
investissements alors que pour on a plus
que 6 ans d'émission rythme actuel
c'est-à-dire qu'en 2030 on aura tout
utilisé notre capacité de de disons de
de d'utiliser des combustibles fossiles
donc c'est assez terrible quand même bon
loin d'être historique pour vous Julien
Baillou c'est quand même un signal ces
COP on sait bien qu'elles sont pas
contraignantes mais il y a quand même
des des mots suffisamment forts pour que
ensuite les industries les marchés
financier s'aligne il y a il y a un élan
c'est ça ça sert à ça aussi non en fait
on est un peu obligé de dire que c'est
mieux si c'était pire voyez c'estàd
qu'en fait si je regarde à quelques
jours d'intervalle on a cru au fiasco ça
a été dit organiser cette COP chez un
état pétroliier ça peut ressembler à une
mauvaise blague euh les les l'OPEP les
états pétroliers ont fait leur lobbying
mais l'Arabie saoudite a laissé passer
ce m de
transition P imaginer que ça échoue
complètement or on a terriblement besoin
d'accord on a terriblement besoin de ces
cadres multilatéraux enfin il n'empêche
que ça c'est si on regarde à quelques
jours on dit ouf il y a un accord si on
regarde à 20 ans parce que c'est il y a
20 ans que Jacques Chirac pour la France
a dit à Johannesbourg la maison brûle et
on regarde d'illeurs ça c'est des grands
mots il faut mettre les pétrol à la
table pour avcer imaginez le degré
d'ambition qu' faille 20 ans pour nommer
les coupables R pour vous bah en fait on
aurait dû aujourd'hui acter la fin des
énergeries fossiles et je voudrais juste
dire un mot c'est qu'en fait la France
là-dedans joue un double jeu vous avez
la ministre de l'énergie qui dit Oh là
indigné que on découvre que le pétrole
fait son lobby
elle n'est pas capable de dire non à
Total qui multiplie les projets
climaticides en Ouganda ou en Tanzanie
elle est pas capable de dire non à
vermillon énergie en Gironde pour H
forages pétroliers nouveaux voyez donc
la France elle-même Emmanuel Macron peut
bien tweter a devant sa porte bien
compris mais mais y compris pour être
crédible parce que en face les pays vous
disent tu le fais pas chez toi comment
voulez-vous me l'imposer Sarah Roussel
pour Greenpeace parce que franchement de
jours avant c'était la douche froide
pour toutes les ONG personne n'imaginait
que l'ensemble des énergies fossiles pas
seulement le charbon comme à Glasgow
aussi le pétrrole et puis le gaz dans un
même accord il faut rappeler quand même
que c'est un consensus donc si quelqu'un
n'est pas d'accord parmi les les pays du
monde entier présents ça ça fait tout
capoter donc pour vous le verre est à
moitié plein ou vide alors nous on est
clairement pour nous sur un bilan mitigé
c'estàdire que on est assez d'accord
pour dire que il y a un cap qui a été
Franch avec cette mention de toutes les
énergies fossiles dans un texte de Cop
et pas seulement du charbon comme ça
avait été le cas à Glasgow et encore on
parlait seulement de la réduction de
notre dépendance au charbon donc il y a
vraiment un cap qui a été franchi un
signal assez fort politique qui est
envoyé mais néanmoins ce n'est pas
l'accord historique que nous attendions
de cette COP qui est la COP du bilan
mondial on le rappelle qui est la COP
aussi qui actualité voilà les accords de
Paris qui s'incrit dans une actualité en
fait les événements climatiques extrêmes
se multiplient on l'a vu cette année
donc l'urgence elle est là il faut agir
maintenant donc c'est pas l'accord
historique dont les pays par exemple en
développement ont besoin on est dans un
texte où comme on le disait il y a une
vague mention d'une transition vers
autre chose que les énergies fossiles
pas de trajectoire pas d'objectifs alors
il y a les 10 ans ça c'est les
Européens la décennie cruciale qui vient
comment comprendre les effets concrets
que peuvent avoir ces 10 ans dans cet
accord sachant que il faut le rappeler
rien n'est contraignant dans ces COP si
10 an avait vraiment de l'importance et
bien nous devraons nous attendre l'idée
l'idée de ce bilan mondial c'est de
repartir sur des bases plus ambitieuses
d'ci 2025 et disons si c être pris au
sérieux par les disons pays producteurs
de de de combustiblees fossiles et au
premier an la Chine et les États-Unis
quand même he et bien on devrait avoir
des propositions très ambitieuses d'ici
2025 je crains qu'on les ait pas
j'aimerais bien moi je voudrais quand
même souligner que que du point de vue
la diplomatie c'est un véritable succès
mais ou moi j'ai vécu avec la la
délégation française disons pendant la
première semaine et il y avait pas ce
pessimiste c'est sûr que la première
semaine les négociateurs sont dans leur
couloir ils ne font pas de compromis
mais on sait très bien que disons ça se
joue au moment du segment ministériel et
c'est drôle parce que les les
climatologues sont plutôt sceptiques
votre collègue maçon d'mot également
François gémen qui est votre collègue du
G lui spécialiste d'émigration lui il a
le côté plus optimiste c'est-à-dire
qu'il dit forcément des des effets parce
que le monde regarde les entreprises
regardent les marchés financiers
regardent et donc ça permet quand même
un infléchissement non euh je le crois
également je je je dis que c'est une
étape importante j'ai repris le
et disons je partage aussi ce que dit
agè P en disant que du point de vue
négociation disons diplomatie
multilatérale c'est un succès tout cela
c'est vrai mais je redis que les pays
préoliers les pays disons le gaz le
pétrole le charbon et bien il y a pas
vraiment de ce pic en 2025 on ne l'aura
pas on l'aura peut-être en 2030 et
encore c'est pas sûr donc je redis que
du point de vue du climatologue nous
allons peut-être baisser vers les 3
degrés c'est ça le problème les 1 et
demi déjà c'est mort le le signal
d'investissement on comprend que ça
envoit un signal d'investissement que
mais simplement ce qui se passe sur le
terrain c'est tout le contraire et
Madame Rousel a raison les événements
climatiques se multiplient mais nous par
exemple on se rue sur le gaz de schiste
américain c'est le terminal méthanier au
Avre qui a été inauguré il y a pas
longtemps ou sur le gaz azerbaïjanais
nous finançons nous-mêmes l'effort de
guerre contre l'Arménie donc on peut
dire que c'est notre allié on paye à
l'Azerbaïjan de quoi envahir l'Arménie
les les inondations se multiplient les
effets du dérèglements climatiques sont
connus mais on a des signaux un peu dans
les terres dans le flou comme C ces
grandes conférences qui sont nécessaires
et par contre sur le N nécess
l'écologistes que vous êtes les considè
comme nécessa absolument parce qu'en
fait sinon paroup de français considèent
que ça sert à rienre l'avion jusquà doub
c'est complè on pourrait avoir ce
sentiment que ça sert à rien mais c'est
sinon ça ne se discute pas ou alors
contre G8 ou pays riches et les États
insulaires les les les pays pauvres ont
absolument besoin de ce cadre et
d'ailleurs maintenant c'est l'en jeu de
l'adaptation voà il va venir alors
justement sur l'adaptation ça ça fait
partie des des limites le manque de
financement le fond perta et dommage
tout le monde a dit la première semaine
formidable enfin euh les premiers pays
du Sud les plus pauvres les plus
impactés par le réchauffement euh ceux
qui n'ont absolument pas beaucoup émis
de de gaz à eff vont pouvoir enfin être
compensés mais quand on regarde euh les
montants alors là franchement c'est pas
au niveau 400 millions euh de de dollars
c'est faible pour compenser les les
dommages comment comment on peut
expliquer ça benah que c'est un travail
en en étape la première étape c'était
d'avoir un un fond qui serait créé mais
dont tout était à construire et la sont
V pendant des années il a été crjà atemp
mais il fallaitageou là on a un
abandement et ça c'était quand même une
des bonnes surprises de la COP c'était
que les accords sont arrivés très vite
sur ce sujet enfin c'était personne
s'attendait à ce que ça arrive aussi
viteétait la grande surprise et ça était
d'ailleurs salué de manière assez massif
par les les journalistes internationaux
qui suivent la COP en disant wouh on
s'attendait pas à des résultats aussi
rapidesut avoir des VO c une manuvre
diplomatique à excusez-moi de de la
présidence en fait de se dire le sujet
des financement c'est toujours un sujet
qui est cristallisant dans les COP
puisqu'il y a toujours cette opposition
nord- sudud avec des pays en
développement qui disent ça fait des
années en fait qu'on vous demande les
financements pour à la fois opérer notre
transition énergétique nous adapter au
changement climatique qui nous impactent
en premier alors qu'on est les moins
responsables et aussi faire face aux
pertes et dommages donc ces fameuses
pertes et dommages qu'on subit déjà donc
dès le premier jour voilà VI de la
montée des EAU les victimes des
canicules de la exactement c'est une
bonne chose mais c'est un fond comme
vous l'avez dit dans lequel aujourd'hui
les contributions sontuteur de 600
millions dollars alors qu'on parle pour
les pertes et dommages de 500 milliards
par an d'ici à 2030 donc c'est largement
insuffisant jean-jousel non ce que je
voulais dire simplement c'est que la la
signature disons la concrétisation du
fond les premiers jours a joué un rôle
assez intéressant ça rétabli un certain
degré de confiance entre pays développés
et pays en voie de développement qui
avait complètement disparu et ça c'est
important je je crois que il faut
rétablir cette idée de solidarité et le
fait je crois que ça a été très
astucieux de la part de d'aljaber de
l'annoncer au départ
quand même ça quand même je pense jouer
dans la durée un rôle plutôt positif
alors il y a le fond sans sans
financement à la hauteur et puis il y a
le triplement des des dans les énergies
renouvelables les les investissements
alors à quoi peut-on s'attendre est-ce
qu'on va avoir des vases communiquants
ou comme vous comme jean- jousel le
pense on va continuer les fossiles tout
en faisant des renouvelables à côté ça
ça a toujours été la problématique quels
que soient les sujets sur l'énergie
malheureusement on a l'impression qu'on
narrive pas à les substituer mais qu'on
les additionne et donc ça c'est
effectivement le sujet très important
sur lequel il faut qu'on soit vigilant
et d'ailleurs on a parl de sobriété
aussi dans cette c ça c'est nouveau
aussi pardon mais il faut le le
souligner et et et donc effectivement de
dire que on va tripler les énergies
renouvelables et le nucléaire pour
arriver justement à dire queon allait en
contrepartie baisser les énergies
fossiles alors je veux bien qu'on joue
sur les mots parce que entre le
transitioning away euh from fossil fuels
qui était la la formule validée versus
le face out honnêtement enfin moi j'ai
une ancienne prof d'anglais la
distinction entre les deux on est quand
même très proche des sujets la sortie
progressive personne ve dire alors je sa
chaque mot compte hein mais c'est quand
même un le mot n est pas oui mais
honnêtement ça dit quand même la même
chose et ça dit qu'on est en train de se
de se détourner de ça et qu'on est
rentré comme l'a très bien souligné euh
çaut dire aussi on a on est rentré dans
l' Foss et c'est acté à l'endroit où les
gens ont le plus milité pour les
fossiles alors même qu'il venaent de
recevoir un courrier hyper pressurisant
quand même 3 jours avant pour expliquer
qu'il fallait surtout pas que c'était
brutalisant cette transformation fossile
que l'ensemble des pays qui éta vous
vous dites qu'on est dans le post
fossile vous êtes d'accord avec ur V est
en train de rentrer je suis pas la seule
à le dire quand on regarde les les
réponses internationales tout le monde
se félicite quand même de cet accord
historique et franchement quand on est à
la COP on se rend compte qu'on a un
décalage entre la vision qu'on peut
avoir en France et moi je enfin je peux
la partager parce que franchement le
climat c'est c'est vraiment une
schizophrénie permanente on se félicite
des avancées qu'on a et on se dit le
lendemain punaise il faut y retourner
parce qu'on est encore pas assez loin
c'est c'est toujours ce va et vient mais
moi je je pense que vraiment ce soir et
devant les gens qui nous regardent il
faut fêter les victoire je le répète
parce que sans ça on crée du désespoir
chez les Français qui ont l'impression
que tout ça ne sert à rien que les COP
alors c'est absolument essentiel qu' a
lieu je pense que c'est ça veut dire ça
veut dire aussi que les énergies
décarbonées comme le nucléaire vont
progressivement je dis bien
progressivement remplacer les fossiles
ça vous le saluez est-ce que vous saluez
la pression qu'a posé la France avec
d'autres bien sûr il y a 20 pays au sein
de la COP qui ont fait en sorte que le
nucléaire soit dans l'accord d'abord je
partage le scepticisme un peu un peu
ambiant quoi c'està-dire que bon
évidemment ça un grand exer exercice de
diplomatie mondiale c'est c'est c'est
c'est jamais évident d'arriver vers des
éléments tangibles et
contraignants demander au monarchie
pétrolière d'organiser une COP c'est un
peu comme demander au dind d'organiser
Noël faut pas s'attendre à ce qu'il y a
des mesures très contraignantes le
renard était dans le poulailler bon
voilà après c'est symboliquement c'est
un engagement important la réalité c'est
qu'à l'heure où on parle je parle du
contrôle de d'éminant
spécialistes énergies fossiles c'est 80
% du mix énergétique mondial donc que
voilà on se rend bien compte que la la
pente elle est raide si on veut si on
veut rattraper le rattraper le temps
pour moi le nucléaire est évidemment une
des une des réponses donc je trouve très
bien qu'elle soit
dedans c'est c'est aussi quand même la
reconnaissance
que que la réponse à la la à la lutte
contre le réchauffement elle vient de
réponse
technologiqu du du progrès technologique
et pas c'est mon point de vue je sais
que c'est pas te solution on vous
montrer un sujet sur ce qu'on appelle la
capture du du carbone le stockage du
carbone tout à l'heure justement pour
donner une réponse en tout cas c'est
dans l'accord mais sur le nucléaire
est-ce que une COP réussi peut
promouvoir le nucléaire non écoutez
c'est pas très sérieux enfin je parle
sous le contrôle de Madame Rousel mais
là j'entends énergie décarbonée et c'est
sûr que le P de flamandville qui ne
marche pas depuis 10 ans ça c'est
décarboné ça produit rien voilà donc en
fait il faut apprendre à faire 100 et
quand on annonce un parc en est
gigantesque d'éolien offshore ça c'est
du concret ça veut dire qu'en quelques
années vous pouvez avoir des vous savez
bien
qu'on faire cette transition avec
uniquement du renouvelable d'un coup d'
se je dis juste comme ça on nous parle
de SMR et de PR donc je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail les nouveauxpr et les
nouvelles petit mini central il y a pas
de prototype c'est-à-dire que ça relève
du dogmatisme il y a pas de prototype de
prototype de SMR les mini centrales et
on nous dit qu'on va en faire partout il
y en a pas donc ça c'est la pensée
magique des sousmarins concr a des
sousmar l'énergie en France décarboné
tous les jours moi désolé Mar avecr et
not marve je suis désolé de vous
contredire le seul SMR il est russe et
il a connu des petits réacteurs nouvelle
génération des petits réacteurs
nucléaires S mais c'est c'est juste que
je trouve ça toujours aussi intéressant
de de remettre un peu les rapports de
force c'estàd qu'on est dans une COP où
il y a une vingtaine de pays qui se sont
alliés à cette ce triplement des
capacités nuclléaire alors qu'il y a
plus de 100 pays qui se sont alliés au
triplement des renouvelables donc un
espèce de décalage fr dans les de hein
la France est dans les deux la France
est dans les deux évidemment mais je
veux dire façon vous connaissez très
bien la position de Greenpace sur le
nucléaire je et je ne veux pas parler à
la place de Monsieur jusel mais les
scientifiques le disent je veux dire
pour maintenir la trajecoire ça dépend
des quel he parce que jean-mar dui
project dans les 10 prochaines années
même le gouvernement nous dit que les
centrales elles verront pas le jour
avant 2036 on est complètement hors
sujet en fait par rapport à l'urgence
climatique actuelle sur le nucléire sur
le nucléaire je bon je pense qu'il faut
peut-être d'abord voir les chiffres pour
la France et ceux à l'échelle planétaire
actuellement à l'échelle planétaire le
nucléaire c'est 2 à 3 % d'énergie finale
même si on tripe à horizon 2050 dans le
cas du du renouvelable c'est horizon
2030 donc si on arrive et il est clair
que même triplé à horizon 2050 ne fera
que disons moins de 10 % de l'énergie
donc si on veut neutralité carbone à
horizon 2050 ce sera avec un
développement massif du renouvelable
c'est très clair ça veut pas dire bon
moi je ne suis pas si opposé au
nucléaire ni bon voilà mais je pense que
je mets l'accent toujours sur la
nécessité de développer les renouvelable
en France la position c'est un peu
différent disons que le nucléaire c'est
25 % de l'énergie donc mais on
resteellement lié au fossil actuell
alors dernier point qu même que entre le
gaz en énergie de transition ce qui est
accès à la à la COP là et le nucléaire
comme énergie de transition et de
soutien à la transition énergétique moi
personnellement mon choix est fait parce
que le nucléaire c'est quand même assez
clair que ça produit pas de CO2 c'est
pas réaliste c'est pas réaliste mais ça
c'est encore une fois c'est un peu TAAC
parce que dans dans la logique
aujourd'hui ça produit le nucléaire en
France et la démonstration on la vit
tous les jours en 1 milliard d'euros
pour une centrale qui ne marche pas je
trouve que ça fait cher le mgaw et la
centrale civo qui est plus jeune que moi
qui est à l'arrêt pour parce que il y a
des des problèmes de maintenance et des
problèmes de sécurité faireiqub
sur par que on a des centrales qui
fonctionnent très
bien les pays du monde av le avait grâce
au nucléaire le bilan carbone de la
France on n serait pas là mais ne nous
ruons pas sur le gaz azerbjanais ou sur
le gaz de Ch voyez
a on pourrait s'en passeraccord ai
transition il faudra qu'on soit vigilant
fa qu'il soit aussi vert que possible et
là encore je crois C accord qui met donc
aussi l'accent et je voulais vous amener
là-dessus sur les solutions
technologiques à savoir la capture et le
stockage du carbone alors bonne ou
mauvaise solution avant de vous entendre
de quoi parle-t-on précisément les
explications de ma Frémont
empilé sur ces étagères des plateaux
remplis d'une sorte de sable du calcaire
un minéral naturel au superpouvoir qui
se transforme en éponge pour absorber du
CO2 notre objectif c'est d'éliminer un
milliard de tonnes de CO2 de
l'atmosphère chaque année
l'horizon35 à 15000 km de là en Islande
cette usine aspire l'air ambiant pour
capter le CO2 qui sera ensuite dissou
dans de l'eau dioxyde de carbone qui
dissou dans l'eau il va arriver par ce
tio
là jusqu'à rentrer dans le puit où il va
être injecté dans le dans la roche
volcanique à une profondeur entre 800 2
km de profondeur le gaz est ensuite
transformé en roche avec avec cette
technique l'usine aspire jusqu'à 4000
tonnes de CO2 par an autre procédé cette
fois en Allemagne cette usine fabrique
une étonnante poudre noire le biochar
est un charbon végétal obtenu en
chauffant des coques de cacao privé
d'oxygène ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que le biochar contient un haut
niveau de dioxyde de carbone on capte le
CO2 et on le fixe dans un produit stable
qu'on peut ensuite épendre dans le sol
et ça constitue ainsi un puit carbone
efficace en France le biochat arrive à
l'état expérimental à Lyon la captation
de carbone est approuvée par les
climatologues du JC comme une voie
indispensable pour atteindre la
neutralité d'ici 2050 en 2050 nous
estimons pouvoir arriver environ à 8
goatonn c'est-à-dire 20 % de capture et
de stockage de CO2 c'est-à-dire que
c'est une une technique une solution
qu'il faut dépliler massivement mais il
restera toujours 4 20 % de CO2 qu'il
faudra qu'il faudra réduire un peu
partout dans le monde des projets de
capture de CO2 se multiplient mais les
procédés reste très énergivore et le
modèle économique suspendu au prix du
carbone jean-jousel alors qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ces technosolutions oui
je je je pense que ce qui est évoqué
dans dans l'accord c'est plutôt le
piégage et stockage du piégeage du
carbone à la sortie d'une centrale
disons voilà et son et son stockage dans
le sous-sol ou dans l'océan c'est bien
ce dont on parle surtout alors il y a il
y a des manières plus vertueuses à
minéralisation le piégeage direct alors
moi-même je suis très impliqué sur le
biochar c'est une bonne façon parce que
l'intérêt du biochar c'est qu'il reste
très longtemps dans le sol donc il
apporte aussi de la disons il il
améliore la productivité du sol et donc
voilà il y a disons on peut pas mettre
toutes les méthode de piégeage stockage
du carbone mais comment il faut les
regarder ces technologies là la capture
le stockage c'est un complément utile ou
c'est quasiment du remplacement non
c'est un complément au mieux et disons
pour moi le principal dis le principal
point alors disons le le stockage
végétal comme le bchard est tout à fait
vertueux je pense le stockage dans le
dans les minéraux comme ça se fait on a
vu en en Islande c'est aussi assez
vertueux mais le stockage disons à à la
sortie d'une centrale il vaudrait mieux
éviter de d'émettre ce ce disons ce gaz
carbonique pour moi il y a un problème
éthique avant tout c'est-à-dire que
disons nous aujourd'hui on va émettre du
gaz carbonique sans trop se préoccuper
puis demander à nos enfants alors pour
moi c'est plutôt petits enfants hein de
de de le piéger dans 20 ans parce que au
mieux même si ça marchait ça marcherait
sur disons peut-être 10 % on voit bien
le le enfin le milliard de tonnes c'est
c'est de l'ordre de 5 % des émissions
actuelles hein et bien euh disons c'est
quand même un problèmétique c'est quand
même extrêmement égoïste de notre part
de faire ça de de notre part
collectivement hein c'est-à-dire on va
émettre on ne fait pas d'effort et puis
on demande voilà aux jeunes ENF voilà
dans 20 ans parce que au mieux ça
marchera dans 20 ans dans 30 ans et
pourtant l'accord conseille son
utilisation même sa promotion je ne suis
pas hostile complètement mais il faut
bien mettre ça en tête la meilleure
façon c'est de diminuer les émissions
c'est très clair Marj moi je trouve que
la position là-dessus de la ministre an
runach est assez claire c'est la
question du captage c'est pour ce qu'on
arrive pas à décarboner par ailleurs
donc c'est pour le carbone résiduel et
aujourd'hui vraiment on aurait tort
d'explorer des solutions pour aller cap
SAF que dans l'accord c'est pas si
simple hein le document final cons son
utilisation pour les secteurs dans
lesquels il est difficile c'est tout ce
écrit de faire baisser les émissions
donc en France on a une stratégie
française qui est très claire sur le
fait que c'est uniquement la captation
pour les le carbone résiduel dont on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui comment se
débarrasser quand on met en œuvre toutes
les autres solutions qu'on peut mettre
en œuvre il y a il y a un certain nombre
d'activités où on n'y arrive pas
autrement et donc la position française
ce sera probablement un travail de
lobbying sur les prochaines copes que de
faire avancer cette prod ce cette
position là qui est assez précurseur sur
la France dans les négociations
internationales dont on peut rappeler à
nouveau qu'elles sont extrêmement
importantes parce que alors moi je
greenpce est favorable à capture de
carbone tout on appelle ça un mirage
technologique je rejoins beaucoup
Monsieur jusel sur la parti morale mais
il y a aussi toute une question déjà de
de de de budget en fait c'est des
technologies qui coûtent extrêmement
cher à déployer donc ça veut dire que
dans le cadre d'une COP en fait c'est
une technologie qui est pas accessible à
tout le monde donc la France le fait
chouette mais quit des autres pays on
est là dans une COP pour négocier des
des des réponses globales au changement
climatique pas les réponses de
quelquesuns et encore une fois des pays
riches et ensuite il y a cette question
de pour moi c'est c'est vraiment ouvrir
la porte à continuer à brûler en fait du
pétrole du charbon et du gaz il y a une
forme d'hypocrisie détournement et
diversion a un pe il y a un peu de
diversion voyez si on prend avec le
plastique par exemple on sait qu'on
produit trop de plastique et il y a des
initiatives intéressante pour aller le
récupérer dans la mer mais tant mieux si
ça se fait un peu mais voyez bien que
l'enjeu principal c'est
d'arrêteryerutant risque comme disait
madame Rousel que quelque part ça nous
be dans un statu un peu confortable en
espérant que ça finisse par fonctionner
voilà très bien ben on va s'arrêter là
je crois qu'on a vu les djux princip
donne un rendez-vous important parce que
moi j'étais à la COP pour les journées 5
et 6 de décembre qui ont été le moment
du lancement du building breakthrough
c'est un moment très important qui va
donner un rendez-vous à Paris en
français ça donne bâtim en gros c'est
c'est vraiment la stratégie secteur
bâtiment qui s'engage pour la transition
et donc à la de Glasgow chaque secteur
devait s'engager c'est le cas maintenant
pour le bâtiment et on donne un très
grand rendez-vous à Paris qui sera un
sommet international sur le sujet du
bâtiment qui sera vraiment on on attend
70 pays je pense que ce sera un très bon
moment la minut pub 2 secondes hein moi
ce que je trouve déprimant c'est c'est
l'écoanxiété c'est un grave problème
dans notre société il faut trouver des
remèdes et les remèdes je pense que ça
passe par par la recherche et c'est
assez enthousiasment de voir des gens
travailler sur des des solutions de
progrès de réponse technologique dans le
génie humain pour pour trouver des
réponses autres que la décroissance et
c'est l'action c'est l'action collective
et individuelle merci beaucoup merci
d'être venu faire ce bilan de la COP 28
à Dubaï avec nous vous restez avec moi
Olivier marlex dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties prix de nous
affranchis ce soir yelgo s'interroge le
président mépriserait-il le Parlement
gros plan ce soir aussi avec Richard
verli dans son billet Europe sur Victor
Orban l'homme qui paralyse l'Union et
puis de quoi nous parlez-vous dans
Bourbon Express ce soir Stéphanie des
piierre des tensions entre les députés
dans cette assemblée des sanctions qui
pleuvent allez on va voir ça les amis
tout à l'heure mais d'abord on va parler
de la droite des républicains avec vous
Olivier marlex vous êtes je le disais un
des architectes du rejet de la loi
immigration lundi dans l'hémicycle un
coup politique qui plonge l'exécutif
dans la crise crise politique vous
détenez une partie de la solution mais
voulez-vous vraiment sortir par le haut
avec un compromis on voit cela dans
l'invitation de thbo ednoc interview
juste après
si on vous invite au Marle c'est parce
que vous êtes au centre du jeu politique
en ce moment ce matin vous avez été reçu
à Matignon avec les autres ténors de
votre parti les républicains une heure
d'entretien avec la première ministre
pour parler du projet de loi immigration
et tenter de trouver un accord Olivier
marlex si vous êtes à même de faire
basculer la balance c'est que le
président du groupe les républicains à
l'assemblée que vous êtes a joué un coup
de maître lundi dernier oui monsieur
minist le débat doit se poursuivre il
doit se poursuivre mais sur la base du
texte de fermeté proposé par le Sénat
c'est le sens de la motion de rejet que
nous soutiendrons voter la motion de
rejet des écologistes cette idée loin
d'être évidente vous en avez la
paternité d'abord partager sur le sujet
le rejet préalable du texte ça
reviendrait que le gouvernement ne
puisse poursuivre la discussion de ce
texte qu'à partir de la copie du Sénat
c'est une solution assez tentante après
on n pas forcément les mêmes motivations
que les écologistes c'est un peu ce qui
est à ce stade me fait hésiter vous êtes
finalement parvenu à convaincre presque
tous les députés de votre groupe de vous
suivre un Paris réussi mais un Paris
risqué car cette stratégie est à double
tranchant il y a des millions de
Français qui regardent les débats que
nous avons et des millions qui vont voir
certains députés des républicains voter
avec Monsieur Lucas qui veut la
régularisation de T les sans papier
accusé d'incohérence et d'opportunisme
par le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
allez désormais devoir montrer que vous
n'avez refusé cette loi que pour en
faire adopter une meilleure sans quoi
les Français majoritairement favorable à
la loi pourrait vous en tenir rigueur
mais alors quel texte êtes-vous prêt à
voter cette question pourrait devenir un
piège pour l'unité de votre groupe
politique si demain on avait un texte
d'une grande fermeté qui ressemble à
celui du du Sénat évidemment on pourrait
le voter nous voulons débattre et
adopter dans son intégralité sans ajout
sans modification
le texte du Sénat alors copie proche ou
copie conforme intransigence ou
souplesse Olivier marlex quelle attitude
allez-vous adopter pendant les ultimes
négociations sur la loi immigration au
fond êtes-vous vraiment prêt un
compromis réponse oui oui bien sûr je
crois que les Français attendent une loi
sur l'immigration attend une loi sur
l'immigration ils n'attendent pas du en
même temps c'est qu'on peut pas ils
attendent moins d'immigration ils
attendent une plus forte maîtrise de
l'immigration or ce ce texte qui
prétendait apporter de nouveaux outils
de fermeté en même temps en même temps
proposait des régularisations massive
pour nous c'est inacceptable et en même
temps créer une nouvelle filière
d'immigration en fait en en permettant
au demandeurs d'asile de travailler dès
le premier jour de leur arrivée en
France dès le dépôt d'une demande
d'asile qu'elle soit justifiée ou pas et
donc leur permettant en fait de
s'installer sur notre pays mais c'est un
compromis qui est réclamé aussi par les
Français un sondage hlable du jour il y
aura une commission mixte paritaire elle
se réunie lundi 17h un compromis ça veut
dire forcément pour garantir ce à quoi
vous tenez de plus lâcher par ailleurs
sur quoi vous êtes prêt à lâcher Olivier
Marx le texte du Sénat est déjà le le
fruit d'une sorte de de de compromis
puisque je vous rappelle qu'il a été
voté par les sénateurs Renaissance les
sénateurs de la majorité d'Emmanuel
Macron les centristes du Sénat aussi
l'ont voté donc c'est déjà un texte qui
est issu de compromision
sén très bien he c'est un texte qui est
de fermeté qui est un texte cohérent et
donc cette version là qui qui nous
convient Emmanuel Macron veut une
solution avant Noël cette CMP donc aura
lieu très rapidement dès lundi 17h
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du calendrier
est-ce qu'il est précipité ou pas non je
pense qu'il fallait il fallait
poursuivre en votant cette motion de
rejet on ne voulait pas arrêter le débat
on ne voulait pas le stopper il y a des
mesures qui sont importantes dans ce
texte notamment toutes les mesures qui
permettent l'expulsion des étrangers
d'un an envie dire d'ailleurs jeis
rappeler à Monsieur Darmanin qu'on les a
déposé je lui rappelé ce matin
d'ailleurs à matigon qu'on les a déposé
il y a 1 an dans la niche des
républicains exactement les mesures
qu'il nous propose aujourd'hui qu' a un
an il nous a dit que non non circulit il
y a rien à voir bon donc évidemment ces
mesures là on est prêt aller voter mais
on votera pas ça à n'importe quel prix
on votera pas ça s'il y a en même temps
des régularisations l'article 4 bis sur
la régularisation dans les métiers en
tention aux conditions du Sénat avec
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet c'est
bon oui
c'est CMP vous le voteriez derrière ça a
l'air oui ça a l'air technique comme ça
mais c'est radicalement différent le
gouvernement proposait un droit un droit
pour tous les clandestins d'obtenir leur
régularisation sous réserve de 2 ans de
de de 3 ans pardon de séjour en France
et de 8 mois dans un métier en tension
c'était de plein droit ils avaient droit
à leur régularisation on a sans doute
des des centaines 200 300000 clandestins
qui remplissent ces conditions donc ça
c'est inacceptable en revanche permettre
au préfet comme il peut déjà le faire
aujourd'hui par la voix d'une circulaire
qui est la circulaire Vals de au cas par
cas de régulariser
euh donc bravo Bruno rotillo oui oui le
compromis qui avait été trouvé au Sénat
est un compromis et c'est très bien
restant là-dessus ça marche Elisabeth
borne vous a reçu ce matin c'est elle
qui a repris en main les négociations
sur ce projet de loi mettant un peu à
l'écart géralde de d'armanin que vous
a-t-elle dit précisément je pense
c'était d'abord pour pour nous écouter
on lui a redit avec Bruno rotaillot avec
Eric chotti que voilà qu'on ne voulait
pas dur en même temps qu'on voulait un
texte de fermeter après je c comprendre
qu'elle avait une majorité à gérer elle
est chef de la majorité je ne doute pas
qu'elle serura se faire entendre de de
sa majorité et avec Gérald daranin vous
ne voulez plus parler Gérald daranin a
été euh très franchi quelques limites en
disant que les députés les républicains
porteraient la responsabilité demain et
cetera enfin en cas d'attentat
terroriste oui c'est ça alors que jeous
avélégance nous avons l'élégance à
chaque fois que il y a un drame dans
notre pays de ne pas mettre en cause sa
responsabilité personnelle vous a
insulté voilà
oui je sais pas mais en tout cas c'est
c'est profondément inélégant et donc
c'est sans doute pas le ton sur lequel
on cherche ça passe mieux avecab borne
est plus
respectueuse le ministre de l'Intérieur
a quand même cette drôle façon de
vouloir s'acheter s'attacher les bonnes
grâces des députés individuellement et
de et de les injurier collectivement
donc ça peut pas marcher c'est pas ça la
bonne méthode première ministre elle est
un peu plus factuel technique et bon le
493 a été apparemment exclu hein par le
Président de la République sur ce texte
il l'a fait savoir lors d'une réunion à
H clos hier soir à l'Élysée ça c'est une
très bonne nouvelle ou attention coup de
bluff possible ça veut dire oui le
président de la République a montré
qu'il était capable de changer d'avis et
personne ne lui entient jamais rigueur
donc il peut continuer euh a priori ça
veut dire respect du Parlement ça veut
dire qu'on ne forcera pas la main de du
Parlement ni de sa majorité ni de ni de
l'opposition euh ça veut dire que nous
avons la responsabilité nous de de
trouver effectivement ça veut dire qu'en
cas d'échec de la CMP vous savez ce que
dira le gouvernement il vous fera porter
le chapeau vous prenez un risque énorme
écoutez on est nous on est prêt on est
prêt à avancer il connaissent no
position on est prêt à assumer nos
responsabilités aucune difficulté làdus
Bruno rotaillot va siéger dans cette
commission mixte paritaire vous êtes
plutôt en position de
force pour vous c'est quoi ce serait un
échec s'il n'y avait pas de conclusion
si elle n'aboutissait pas ça dépend non
ça va dépendre de la capacité de la
majorité à mettre tout le monde d'accord
dans ses rangs quand même aujourd'hui le
sujet il est là nous on est totalement
en accord avec les sénateurs les
républicains on l'a dit le groupe des
Républicains à l'assemblée a pris motion
il y a y a 15 jours pour dire qu'on
soutenait on voulait le rétablissement
je vous ai entendu dire que ou en tout
cas d'autres de votre camp que le
compromis du du Sénat n'était pas assez
dur hein certains on pe dire en tout cas
non non il y a une il y a une motion
voté l'unanimité par le groupe disant on
veut le rétablissement du texte du Sénat
donc nous notre position elle est très
claire ce qu'il est moins c'est
qu'effectivement il semblerait que des
députés de la majorité ne veuillent pas
euh le texte que les sénateurs de la
majorité ont accepté c'est c'est là
qu'il faut chercher l'incohérence et
s'il y avait un échec c'est de ce
côté-là vous savez qu'il y a des
cavaliers législatifs dans le compromis
trouvé par le Sénat je sais pas sur
l'aide médicale d'État notamment écoutez
ni vous ni moi ne sommes membres du
Conseil constitutionnel donc je serai
pas présomptuux je ser pas que ça relève
d'une loie de
finance on sait pas le conseila le
Conseil constitutionnel non par qu'onous
dit aussi qu' dispostion sur la
nationalité qui serait cavalier en fait
on n sait rien Dr du
solnement mis dans son texte initial des
dispositions concernant le droit du sol
à mayott donc à priori la question de la
nationalité vous ne serez pas les seul
l'unité nationale du territoire nation
il est normal que les questions de la
nationalité et leur place dans le texte
Conseil constitutionnel prendra lui
aussi ses responsabilité le moment venu
pas trop deouille politique franchement
Olivier Marlec dans tout ça il y a pas
trop de stratégie est-ce que c'est
lisible pour vos
électeurs une stratégie très claire de
notre part c'est le refus des
régularisations massives ça on est
entièrement d'accord c'est le refus de
de l'accueil massif des des des
demandeurs d'asile on va sans doute
arriver cette année à 200000 demandeurs
d'asile vous vous rendez compte on était
à 30000 surous le quinquen Nicolas
Sarkozy on était à 100 56000 en 2022 on
va probablement terminer l'année à
200000 il faut arrêter c'est un c'est un
dévoiement total des règles de de de
l'asile c'est une filière d'immigration
clandestine et le le le gouvernement euh
s'apprête à renforcer les droits en fait
des des des des des pseudo demandeurs
d'asile des vrais faux demandeurs
d'asile donc oui on assume parfaitement
d'avoir été d'une grande fermeté d'une
totale fermeté sur ce sujet-là d'une
certaine intransigence qu'on m'a qu'on
m'a reproché mais euh voilà pour moi
c'est impossible de voter un texte qui
aurait aggravé aggravé la situation de
la France le gouvernement a beaucoup
plus monsieur Darmanin a beaucoup plus
communiqué sur l'expulsion des 4000
étrangers délinquants que sur la
régularisation de 300000 clandestins euh
ou euh de l'accueil de centaines de
milliers euh de demandeurs d'asile
supplémentaires voilà donc ils ne savent
peut-être pas tout ce qui se joue à
travers ce texte nous on le sait ce qui
se joue et on serait coupable d'accepter
euh ces mesures euh totalement laxistes
les Français ils attendent un texte qui
permett la reprise en main de
l'immigration pas euh le laisser aller
très cl sur la stratégie il y a
l'impasse possible hein sur
l'immigration on verra ce que donne la
CMP puis s'il y a un vote ce qu'il donne
dans l'hémicycle et puis il y a la crise
politique pourquoi vous n'appelez pas la
dissolution comme le rassemblement
national est-ce que vous avez peur de
revenir aux urnes le c'est c'est la
responsabilité du Président de la
République moi j'observe c'est que cette
Assemblée nationale elle elle a réussi à
fonctionner quand même depuis euh trou
oui on a voté quand même pas mal de de
texes le rassemblement je crois le
rassemblement national lui-même a signé
à votter pardon 40 % des textes voilà
alors qu'il a pas beaucoup d'influence
et de capacité à les à les
influencer je pense que c'est un peu une
posture cette demande de c'est pas la
peur pense queassemblement national
c'est plutôt une posture ils n pas ils
n'ont pas envie de anticiper ils rêvent
de l'élection présidentielle directement
ils ont raison Madame Le Pen et T
position aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
feriez alors si vous étiez à la place
d'Emmanuel Macron pour sortir de la
crise j'ai pas de dissolution
aujourd'hui parce que je crois
sincèrement que ça rendrait le pays
encore plus ingouvernable sondage monre
qu'on aurait la même assemblée nationale
en pire donc moi je veux pas vous auriez
beaucoup de sièges à perdre aussi force
pardon vous auriez des sièges à perdre
les sondages je suis pas sûr savez on
est un peu on est un peu tout en bas de
la ligne de de flottaison donc je pense
pas qu'on puisse en perdre beaucoup plus
peut-être faut jamais être présomptueux
évidemment face aux électeurs mais c'est
la majorité qui aurait beaucoup pour en
perdre sans doute et on aurait une
assemblée qui serait tout aussi tout
aussi ingouvernable vous souhaitez
gouverner vous souhaitez que votre futur
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
l'emporte j'imagine qu'est-ce que vous
feriez dans Parel pareil assemblée avec
comme ça trois blocs qui ne peuvent pas
avoir la majorité d'abord pardon mais
cette Assemblée nationale elle est le
résultat d'une politique elle est pas né
par hasard c'est une stratégie que je
trouve un peu détestable de fracturation
du pays on reproche souvent de pas aimer
le président de la républi euh ce que je
lui reproche profondément c'est pour moi
le président la République il est garant
de l'unité nationale il utilise le mot
de temps en temps mais ce qu'il a fait
depuis 6 ans il a beaucoup joué des des
des fractures du pays parce qu'il
voulait pous il voulait pas qu'il a
d'alternative à gauche et à droite donc
il voulait il a voulu pousser les
électeurs de gauche dans les bras de
Monsieur Mélenchon et pousser les
électeurs de droite dans les bras de
Madame Le Pen ce petit jeu il est mortel
pour le pour le pays il a fracturé le
pays et cette Assemblée nationale c'est
le résultat de de de la politique de
fracturation alors peut-ê une solution
un véritable contrat de coalition avec
une liste de réformes que vous écririez
un premier ministre
cettebut on veut pas vous n'entrerez
jamais au gouvernement on ne veut pas de
non on veut pas cette responsabilité
avec Emmanuel Macron sans avoir c'est on
a été élu comme député de d'opposition
après dans cette assemblée moi je crois
que les Français ont émis un Français
ils ont pas ils ont ils ont pas donné de
majorité à Emmanuel Macron ils ont donné
de majorité à personne d'autre ils ont
mis un peu le président de la République
sous sous tutelle en quelque sorte de
l'Assemblée
nationaleise veulent l'obliger
effectivement il nous obligent nous à
prendre nos responsabilités ils obligent
le président de la République à écouter
à respecter le Parlement je pense que
c'est la volonté des Français travers
ces élections on va continuer en parler
du Parlement dans les parti pris de nos
affranchi merci beaucoup Olivier marlex
on va scruter évidemment cette
commission mixte paritaire de très près
mais d'abord nos affranchis qu'on
accueille tout de suite Ilg de France
interre et Richard Verly de bque
quotidien suisse bienvenue à vous deux
installez-vous on commence comme chaque
soir par Bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée c'est Stéphanie
Despierre qui nous la raconte ce soir
bonsoir St
une histoire de climat un climat délé
terire qui règne dans cette Assemblée
nationale ça avait été le cas pendant la
réforme des retraites et ça recommence
avec la loi immigration grosse montée de
tension évidemment lundi le rejet du
projet de loi par la coalition des
oppositions a électrisé le Palais
Bourbon hier la tension était encore
très perceptible lors de la la séance de
question gouvernement Brouis invective
un moment on entendait vraiment plus
rien et surtout la présidente des
députés écologistes accuse même son
voisin d'hémicycle le député naissance
Jean-René casenu on le voit à l'image de
l'avoir menacé il lui a lancé toi tu
seras tondu à la Libération pour avoir
voté avec le rassemblement national
alors Miriam nous n'avons pas les images
ni le son car tout ça s'est déroulé hors
champ des caméras mais cyiel châelin
explique que la que ça s'est produit
après son intervention alors qu'elle
vait d'expliquer qu'elle était fière
d'avoir rejeté cette loi immigration
c'est quand elle s'assoit que le député
Renaissance la prend à parti je lui ai
demandé de répéter ce qu'il a fait
c'estd que c pas un propos qu'il a ten
une fois un propos qu'il a tenu deux
fois à mon encontte et après je le
reconnais je me suis mis en colère mais
une colère que j'estime légitime
c'est-à-dire que mon propos est de lui
dire c'est une menace c'est sexiste
c'est extrêmement violent c'està-
direire que la tonte c'est l'attaque à
l'intégrité physique des femmes c'est
l'humiliation publique et c'est une
manière de dire aux femmes taisez-vous
et donc c'est une intimidation sexiste
alors plusieurs témoins ont confirmé à
la scène la présidente des écologistes a
écrit à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale pour am des sanctions contre
le député Renaissance Jean-René cas
qu'on a réussi à joindre confirme un
échange avec Cyril châelin mais il
Démont formellement avoir tenu les
propos qu' lu prête oui climat délétaire
depuis le début en fait de cette
discussion sur la loi immigration déjà
en commission la semaine dernière avec
une altercation oui c'était il y a 10
jours les députés ont failli en venir
auain
regardezette conditione ça c'est
toujours
ici
[Musique]
sera donc on reconnaî go bernalicis on
reconnait Go bernalicis qui donc a été
sanctionné ça a été c'est officiel
depuis ce matin par les les instances de
l'Assemblée nationale il est privé
pendant un mois de la moitié de son
indemnité alors les les insoumis
dénoncent un deux poids de mesure trop
de sanctions à le rcontre et sur ce
cas-là une légitime défense
parlementaire il faut dire que ce matin
il y a eu une pluie de sanctions décidé
à la réunion de bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale 8 sanctions alors contre des
députés de plusieurs partis pas que
l'opposition il y a eu même une députée
écologiste Sandra rogol qui perd un/4 de
son d'indemnité car toujours en
commission sur la loi immigration elle
accusait le rassemblement national de
n'avoir jamais pris en compte les
affaires de violence sexuelle qui
touchent le parti elle répondait à une
des accusations du rassemblement
national qui expliquait que les
écologistes étaient des amis des
violeurs du Hamas alors on le voit myiam
ce climat est éé délétaire éruptif et le
nombre de sanctions atteint des records
il y en a eu 16 entre 2017 et 2022 nous
sommes à 145 depuis juin 2022 145 alors
la présidente de l'Assemblée espère que
la salve du jour calmera un peu tous ses
esprits échauffés h qu'est-ce qui se
passe Olivier marnx immigration ça n
fait perdre Assemblée nationale est
malheureusement à l'image de la
radicalisation du du du du pays et par
tout à l'heure cette fracturation cette
radicalisation la France insoumis joue
prend une part particulière quand même
hein dans ce notamment dans le nombre de
sanctions je pense que c'est eux qui qui
sont en haut en haut des compteurs bon
voyez moi j'ai été collègue d'Ugo
bernalicis pendant 6 ans en commission
des des des lois vous surprendre en
disant que c'est un garçon pour qui
j'ai du du respect par ailleurs et
euh vaut beaucoup mieux que ça mais là
on a une vraie crise de d'hystérie de sa
part qui a duré un quart d'heure pour
empêcher les débats c'est c'est
inacceptable il vaut il vaut beaucoup
mieux que ça il était normal de de
sanctionner ce on peut être en dacord
pas quand même le stin que voilà il y a
une forme de crise politique à travers
cette assemblée qui est dans une forme
d'usure prématurée qu'il faut absolument
changer c'est pas c'est même pas c'est
comme ça depuis le premier jour c'est
pas une usure prématuréélration c'est la
photographie malheureusement de l'état
de notre pays regardez le nombre de
crisees depuis malheureusement 2017
depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est élu enfin
si depuis qu'il est élu on a eu la crise
des gilets jaunes on a eu la crise de
banlieu on a accumulé on a accumulé les
crises je pense que cette espèce de de
de
oui une part le présent la République a
dit que les parlementaires étaient
cyniques je pense que malheureusement il
en a pas manqué depuis depuis 2017 et
c'est pas pour rien dans les C nombre de
crisees de notre pays vous allez voir
justement Emmanuel Macron est-il
indifférent au Parlement c'est votre
parti prix ce soir yel Go près de 20
mois après après sa réélection oui parce
que la façon dont le président minimise
minore la crise qui a éclaté lundi avec
l'adoption de la motion de rejet
préalable cette attitude interroge en
tout cas on est dans une forme moi je
dis de dénis qui se décline en plusieurs
nid puisque c'est ni dissolution la
réaction il a confirmé à ses autes de la
majorité reçu hier soir à l'Élysée ni
493 ni retrait du texte il veut même que
ça finisse vite que ça passe ou sa casse
lundi en commission mixte paritaire ni
référendum ni remanimement à chaud
puisqu'il refuse que Gérald armanin
démission grosso modo ce ne serait donc
qu'une péripétie circulé il y a presque
rien à voir pas une crise et les
éléments de langage qui redescendent de
l'Élysée consistent à se dédoiner pour
mieux cibler
l'irresponsabilité des oppositions leur
jeu du pire je cite le cynisme du psdlr
en conseil des ministres il a même eu
cette phrase du président le vote de
lundi ne révèle pas l'existence d'une
majorité de substitution mais vise à
bloquer le pays on en est là 270 députés
représentants du peuple réduits au
statut de bloqueur qu'est-ce qui vous
gêne alors dans ce propos présidentiel
bah ça confirme l'incapacité du
président à intégrer la nouvelle donne
de 2022 réélu il est passé à côté des
législatives les fameux 100 jours s
sanss très bien raconté par mon confrère
Ludovic vigogne cette scène
rappelez-vous sur le tarmac dorly
mi-juin dans notentre deux tours
injonction du président aucune voix ne
doit manquer à la à la République comme
si votait nupes LR RN ou autre chose
étaent criminel extrême centre totale
personnification ce cercle de la raison
contre tous les autres forcément
déraisonnable on connaît la suite il
devient le premier président réélu avec
une aussi faible majorité et bien 18
mois plus tard rien n'a changé ou
presque dans sa conception des forces en
présence au Parlement alors que tout a
changé par rapport au premier mandat sur
la loi immigration le dépassement bah ça
aurait pu fonctionner en majorité
absolue mais il est dépassé quand gauche
droite et extrême droite retrouve ou
accroissent leur poids politique plutôt
que du deux en un il aurait dû faire du
1 + 1 un texte pour intégrer la gauche
aurait pu suivre un texte pour expulser
la droite aurait pu soutenir et d'après
vous il ne tire pas les leçons de cet
échec bah pas à chaud en tout cas pas à
chaud il met la pression même pour que
la CMP aboutisse dès lundi soir alors
même qu'au Sénat à l'Assemblée on on
plaidait pour faire une petite pause
pour mieux renégocier derrière défiance
méfiance c'est du déjà vu par le passé
rappelez-vous le 493 sur les retrait et
la censure évité à neuf voix près et
alors c'était son engagement de campagne
c'était sa légitimité nous disait
l'Élysée et puis il y a eu les CNR les
formats Saint-Denis avec chef de parti
pas les élus les conventions citoyennes
ce sont des artifices des inventions
plus ou moins éphémères pour contourner
le Parlement aujourd'hui cette motion de
rejet lui revient en boomerang il est
temps qu'Emmanuel Macron intègre le
législatif à son logiciel exécutif c'est
pas j'impose et il ou elle dispose vous
ne changez pas une virgule j'imagine pas
une virgule sur ça non non c'est
juste dans dans le premier mandat je
crois que tout le monde c'était un peu
accorder à à reconnaître que le
Président de la République avait un peu
de mal avec les les les corps
intermédiaires quoi avit un peu de mal
peut-être même d'ailleurs avec des
premier ministres qui auraiit trop de
personnalité enfin euh et et évidemment
ça n ça n'a pas changé quoi
effectivement il a du mal à à intégrer
ce qui est le rôle du du Parlement il y
a besoin de respect il y a besoin
d'écoute si on veut arriver à construire
des choses moi j'observe que la première
ministre voilà sans sans sans sans faire
de bruit euh arrive pe pe auprou à
construire un peu cette euh alors
peut-être on vient ne faire parvenir
cette information à l'instant euh qu'il
y a de l'écoute et un peu de respect
dans les propos de Bruno l maire dans un
article au Figaro àaraître demain euh
qui appelle le gouvernement enfin en
tout cas le Parlement plutôt c'est c'est
évidemment les députés de la commission
mixte paritaire à reprendre la version
du Sénat ça va vous faire plaisir avec
deux bémoles euh l'aide médicale d'État
et l'accès aux aides sociales que vous
avez considérablement durci he 5 ans de
résidence en France au lieu de de 3 mois
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour vous c'est
une maint que dans la majorité des gens
entendent qu'il a besoin de que le texte
du Sénat était vraiment la la bonne
copie de de de départ voilà après il est
pas membre c'est une base de compromis
le Sénat moins la me et l'accès aux
aides sociales il est pas membre de la
de la CMP voilà mais euh en tout cas
partir du Sénat je retiens avance allez
on termine avec vous Richard verli
sommet européen de Bruxelles de demain
jeudi et vendredi au menu les
négociations sur l'adhésion au non de de
l'Ukraine dans dans l'Union ce que
refuse le Premier ministre Victor Orban
du moins s'il n'obtient pas le déblocage
de quelques dizaines de milliards
d'euros d à son pays alors oui si vous
voulez savoir comment va l'Union
européenne et bien vous suivez les
déclarations de Victor Orban ce trait
nationaliste Premier ministre hongrois
reçu à dîner à l'Élysée au début
décembre par Emmanuel Macron au fond il
y a un seul mot d'ordre pour ce chef du
gouvernement qui faut qui qui fut
autrefois un défenseur des libertés et
des droits de l'homme la Hongrie d'abord
l'intérêt des Hongrois d'abord les fonds
communautaires pour Budapest d'abord
vous avez bien saisi tout est simple
dans l'Europe de Victor Orban la Hongrie
a besoin du gaz russe alors pas question
de se mettre à dos Vladimir Poutine son
parti de droite Durre le fidch qui est
anti immigrant et réactionnaire et bien
alors vive Donald Trump dont Orban
souhaite ouvertement le retour à la
présidence des États-Unis et puis il y a
l'Ukraine avec qui les 27 doivent
décider ou non d'ouvrir les négociations
d'adhésion pour Orban c'est non enfin
sauf si Bruxelles débloque les fonds
gelés pour non respect de l'État de
droit c'estàd mise sous tutelle de la
justice par l'exécutif hongrois
bienvenue dans l'Europe du chantage
l'idée d'un destin commun est totalement
foulé au pied Orban c'est le chacun pour
soi et le détricotage de la communauté
de l'Intérieur en se servant
copieusement au passage et sans même
dire merci alors que son pays a
grandement bénéficier de l'élargissement
de 2004 ils faut donc dire oui à
l'Ukraine et ne pas l'écouter bah au
contraire le pire en fait c'est que
Victor Orban et son chantage tuent
l'indispensable débat européen sur
l'Ukraine le Premier ministre hongrois
n'a pas tort lorsqu'il alerte sur la
déstabilisation agricole qui résulterait
d'une entrée de l'Ukraine trop anticipée
dans l'Union européenne il n'a peut-être
pas tort non plus lorsqu'il cible la
bureaucratie de Bruxell qui confond
parfois ses intérêts avec ceux des pays
membres le drame c'est sa méthode de
raquetteur au fond pour Orban Zelenski
et l'Ukraine c'est une variable
d'ajustement un peuple se bat un
dictateur russe veut abattre nos
démocrati mais Orban lui jongle avec un
total cynisme il approuve les sanctions
si elle n'impacte pas son pays il cajole
la Russie tout en bénéficiant de la
protection de l'OTAN Victor Orban il
joue parfaitement son rôle c'est celui
d'un poison européen contre lequel nous
n'avons pas d'antidote Orban poison
européen l'homme de droite vous reprenez
les mots non euh moi je reprocherai
jamais à un chef d'État ou de
gouvernement de défendre l'intérêt
national de son de son pays alors
évidemment c'est au extrêmes de ce que
la France a toujours fait France qui
défend toujours l'idée européenne avant
son propre intérêt national on est un
peu on a un peu une exception en Europe
il serait temps d'ouvrir les yeux merci
à vous on s'arrête là allez merci il a
été suspendus mais c'est fini on
s'arrête là on va essayer de regarder en
coulisse un peu ce qui se trame sur
cette commission mixte paritaire vous
savez quel CP suit ça comme le lait sur
le feu merci les affranchis et Merci à
VOUS Olivier marlex dans le fauteuil du
grand témoin ce soir c'est la fin de
cette émission à voir ou à revoir sur la
chaîne Youtube de LCP soirée
documentaire à présent avec Jean-Pierre
Grassin très bonne soirée à
[Musique]
demain